it's kind of a love story bella thorne
and her ex Tana mojo are feuding on
Twitter and honestly you guys there is
so much drama to unpack here let's dive
in it all started when the former Disney
star took to social media to let people
know how she was feeling about her
ex-girlfriend quote Tana and I are no
longer good she broke girlcode
I'm over it but Bella didn't go on to
explain herself leaving many fans
wondering what the hell man I could wake
up on the wrong side of the bed I might
wake up and I'm like no one with me this
morning Tana seemed just as shook and
responded writing imagine taking every
time you're mad at me to Twitter but
then telling people how much you care
about me WTF is this be ouch naturally
it got worse with Bella retweeting Tana
and adding quote you legit started
dating me for Twitter how about you
answer your phone and talk to me instead
of being on Twitter the back-and-forth
got more heated with Tana clapping back
that she had been texting Bella since
that very first week quote dude what are
you doing Bella like I have no idea why
you're mad I've been texting you every
minute since you tweeted and for you to
be tweeting me something as hurtful as
saying I dated you for Twitter is
literally [ __ ] nuts and if you
honestly think that damn I lost you
that's when the convo appeared to be
taken offline confused same there are
some clues as to what Tana possibly did
and his name is Maude son I wish that
didn't dig as deep as it did now you
might remember Bella and Tana were in a
publicly open relationship for nearly a
year while Bella was also with rapper
Maude son in February Bella announced on
Twitter that she and Tana had split and
in April Bella and Maude called it quits
now get this Maude in Tana were spotted
at dinner together earlier this week
could this be the girl code Bella's
speaking of it is not right okay their
dinner outing was also interesting
because
Tanna is engaged to Jake Paul he's
mainly into me but like I don't I've
been keeping it low-key Jake Moore went
public with it
yeah unfortified
weird but they did and then it it Jake
this is a better match if I'm being
honest the two got engaged in June in
Vegas
that photo registered to a party at the
club
[Applause]
anyway following news of their
engagement Bella took to social media to
let people know how she was feeling
about it sharing this tear-filled pic
with the caption when your ex gets
engaged I never fake cry Tana and Jake
are set to tie the knot in Las Vegas at
the graffiti mansion on July 28th with
MTV cameras rolling you love me
according to a press release about the
pair's upcoming nuptials the wedding
will be followed by a reception at the
Sugar Factory which will feature a full
red carpet of course while no guests
have been confirmed the event is
promised to be star-studded Jake
revealed the wedding date to a crowd at
VidCon naturally and as Tana and Jake
bask in pre marital bliss
Bella's love life is revving up to just
a week after news of tannaz engagement
broke Bella posted a series of cuddly
pics with boyfriend Benjamin Maskull Oh
from a trip to Italy she captioned this
puckered up pic quote I'm very happy
with you this story is wild and
something tells me that it's far from
over so make sure to keep it locked
right here on ET for all the updates
until next time I'm Hallie Stephens bye
for now
[Music]